pour changer depuis 20 ans liang gagnon
donne une deuxième vie à des
électroménagers brisé avec les années
aux deux communes de milliers
d'appareils on a pêché au dépotoir
son constat la qualité des
électroménagers diminue et pièces de
rechange sont coûteuses et difficiles à
trouver
malgré tout plusieurs de ses clients 1 6
2 pour réparer plutôt que de jeter
l'accès à l'information et donc l'accès
aux pièces et cette idée gagnent en
popularité
un peu partout dans le monde dans les
rues pierre café des bénévoles offrent
leur expertise pour réparer des objets
abîmés
l'idée est née à amsterdam il ya dix ans
et a voyagé jusqu'ici on compte
désormais 28 8 et un café au canada le
collège dawson en collaboration avec
l'entreprise un certain qu a tenu son
premier et partons on a tellement
l'habitude de jeu se jeter puis acheter
du neuf mais non quand même il ya plein
de façons de faire
sinon c'est juste quelque chose de petit
qui brisent ipsa serait pas fascinant
comme cet ordinateur par exemple c'est
tellement facile de jetter et pour moi
j'ai je connais pas les aureilhanais
tellement donc je vais être sûr que
c'est fini les individus commencent à se
renseigner pour savoir que où est ce
qu'ils peuvent rapporter justement
l'électroménager dont ils n'ont plus
l'utilité
mais la partie n'est pas gagnée et les
réflexes loin d'être acquis tout le
monde fait ça tout le monde à un terroir
avec plein de cellulaires dedans en
pensant qu'un jour il va se servir de
son téléphone intelligent mais c'est pas
vrai les chargeurs sont plus adaptées la
batterie fonctionne plus donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça et surtout à qui
revient la responsabilité
toutes les parties prenantes ont leur
leur travail à faire là que ça soit
autant de la part
des gouvernements pour légiférer faire
en sorte que justement il soit
impossible de programmer l'obsolescence
des produits et en attendant que les
gouvernements s'attaquent définitivement
problème de l'obsolescence
les citoyens peuvent déjà réfléchir à
leur consommation
ici qui me remettrai au canada montréal